welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and werewolf by night has officially
introduced man thing to the MCU in all
of his swampy Snuffaluffagus glory and I
for one am so excited to have one of
Marvel's oldest and oddest heroes in the
MCU but when could we see Mr Man thing
pop up again because we have got to know
just how this hideously hilarious human
object hybrid monstrosity came to be
well my nerd babies though man thing may
have gotten his start in the dark magic
corners of Marvel what if I told you
that it is quite possible that we could
see man things mushroomed mug pop up in
Sam Wilson's first Solo movie Captain
America New World Order I know sounds
crazy but let's speculate on this
together my nerd babies because I don't
think it's as crazy as it sounds but
first do not forget to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our latest Obsession shirts inspired by
both She-Hulk and House of the Dragon my
beautiful nerd babies these are not
going to last forever I'm telling you so
head on over to new Rockstar of
merch.com and buy ourselves some shirts
for your torso today alright so watch
werewolf by night I'm sure nobody was
actively thinking about how this
monstrous man thing could potentially
tie into the plot of Captain America new
world order but now we know that the
long-awaited leader is going to be the
film's main antagonist I think this
could actually be possible because
though the hunters in werewolf By Night
perceive man thing as merely yet another
bad monster that is a threat to humanity
they could not be further from the truth
because much like Jack Russell wasn't
always a werewolf man thing wasn't
always a giant swamp elephant because
like Jack and Elsa called him in
werewolf by night man thing's real name
was actually Ted you have a lovely name
and very similar to another big green
lovable monster in the MCU Ted's
transformation into the man thing
actually has its roots in none other
than War what is it good for absolutely
nothing but also super soldier funding
yeah like Bruce Banner biochemistry
Professor Ted Salas of Empire State
University was recruited by the United
States military in order to lead a
secret government project called project
sulfur and later a project called
Gladiator that focused on recreating a
super soldier serum a serum that would
ideally morph their soldier's genetic
makeup to make them completely immune to
any type of biochemical Warfare intense
Alice was obsessed with this project
often referred to a serum as his
attempts to create Captain America 2.0
because he had a passion for protecting
and healing soldiers through the
upgrading of humankind much like both
MCU Bruce Banner and Betty Ross had when
they were tricked by the military into
thinking that they were working on
curing soldiers of radiation poisoning
not gonna lie I've been waiting for an
excuse to do a big howl this entire
video and now I've got the perfect
excuse because epic hero shock has a
brand new werewolf finite t-shirt just
for you and it's perfect for those times
when you wanna let your inner Beast out
or you just want a shirt to let people
know how awesome you thought werewolf by
night was because it was very awesome
and hey if werewolves aren't your thing
but you still want to be both nerdy and
creepy this Halloween there's plenty of
more options for you in the shop Empire
of Darkness features a lone Mando
fighting off hordes of zombie clone
troopers which is super dope or you can
get an Agatha all along T if you want an
excuse to sing mcu's catchiest villain
jingle all day long and if your spooky
tastes overlap with your cutesy taste
you might be more into the melty Scarlet
Vision tea and if you're a long time fan
of new rock stars who wants to rib us
for being so certain that Mephisto is
joining the MCU last year that epic hero
shop has the Mephisto tea that you need
right here like this is the absolute
best way to support the channel and
wearing the merch is the best way to
spot fans in the wild
yeah
where are they I think they're talking
about us
to make sure to wear it to screamings
parties or while handing out candy to
the neighborhood kids and also be sure
to tag at epic hero shop and use the
hashtag real epic hero to get featured
on their page so get everything you need
to be the stylish nerd that you know
that you are at Epic heroshop.com
anyways it turns out that the bad guys
at aim Advanced idea mechanics heard
that old boy Teddy was chilling in the
Florida Everglades getting so close to
recreating a super soldier serum that
they convinced his girlfriend that
wasn't you know being paid attention to
because he was so obsessed with science
to betray him to that very criminal
organization causing tetsalis to destroy
his research and then go on a high-speed
chase through the Florida swamps forcing
Ted to have no other choice but to
inject himself with the very super
soldier serum that they were after
however due to his car crashing into a
swamp combined with a flaw in his very
formula the serum did end up saving his
life but at the cost of absorbing the
essence of the swamp that he was
actually in into his biology and
morphing to Ed Salas into the Mindless
brute of a man thing now this all being
said man thing's connection to the
American Military super soldier program
is exactly why I believe man thing could
potentially make a cameo in Captain
America New World Order because if you
remember from the 2008 Hulk movie when
Samuel Stearns first appeared as Bruce
Banner's Mr Blue that weird ass nerd was
also obsessed with the legacy of the
super soldier program and upgraded
Humanity to eradicate sickness and
disease this is potentially Olympia
technology has Limitless applications
we'll unlock hundreds of cures we will
make humans impervious to disease so
much so that he went behind Bruce
Banner's muscly Greenback and replicated
the blood samples that Bruce Banner sent
to him to try to do so and I think this
is the main reason why Marvel Studios
chose him as the villain of a Captain
America movie because the leader himself
owes his entire arrayed Cranium to
Abraham erskine's super soldier serum
and since we know that every single
Captain America movie has dealt with the
legacy of the super soldier serum in
different ways I expect Captain America
new world order to be no different and
we could likely see a flashback of the
origins of Ted's Alice's work on Project
Gladiator and his subsequent
transformation into the man thing at
some point in that movie as part of the
leader's Research into enhancing the
human genome especially since the
She-Hulk show just revealed the leader's
Intelligentsia as the mysterious group
that is after she Hulk's blood because
with Steve Rogers gone Isaiah Bradley
M.I.A and Hydra super soldiers with a
bullet in their head cursed of Zemo
there are not a lot of specimens for
Samuel Stearns to study in his quest to
upgrade Humanity to their ultimate
potential much like Bruce's blood did
for his brain I believe that there is a
massive chance here that She-Hulk is not
the only child of the super soldier
serum that the leader in his
intelligencia team are interested in
analyzing because as another piece of
super soldier science seeing himself man
thing tensalis is as well and I for one
would love to see Hulk She-Hulk Isaiah
Bradley and man thing team up as
siblings of the super soldier serum to
take down the leader in his secret
Sinister super soldier plans together
led by the high-flying new Captain
America Sam Wilson that'd be super cool
just to see that symbolic super soldier
team despite the leader because they all
owe their existences to Steve Rogers and
Abraham Erskine but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at Mass retainment on
Twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the social
medias and when you follow us on YouTube
make sure you hit that Bell so that you
can get notifications every time we
upload a video but again thank you guys
so much for watching I appreciate your
time so much and I'll see you guys later
bye
[Music]